des grillons des blattes des fourmis
bienvenue dans la maison des insectes
le site ouvert depuis 2010 est sur la
commune de carrières sous poissy propose
aux visiteurs de s'approcher au plus
près de ses résidents pas comme les
autres tous les terrariums qui sont là
derrière nous c'est uniquement des
petites bêtes vivantes
et donc le concept c'est de travailler
un peu sur les idées reçues qu'on se
fait sur les petites bêtes qu'est ce
qu'on ressent quand on voit une arrivée
qui passe une mouche qui vole à côté de
nous qu'est ce qu'on ressent en voyant
des petites bêtes comme ça en plus de la
quinzaine de terrariums le site dispose
également d'une volière à papillons de
25 mètres carrés donc c'est une volière
à papillons tropicaux uniquement où on
présente une entre trente et quarante
espèces différentes de papillons de jour
et quelques papillons de nuit paris si
vous avez le papier un des plus grands
papillons me qui existe qui est apte à
cus atlas donc là vous avez une grosse
femelles de papillons de nuit est juste
là un fabien qu'on appelle marge et moi
une recette qui fonctionne la maison des
insectes attire entre 60 et 100
visiteurs par jour depuis le début du
monde parce que pour ça tu découvres
différentes sortes d'insectes
je savais que la mygale existent et les
gens n'avaient jamais vu en vrai des
bêtes qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
si vous voulez on a toujours l'habitude
dé des mouches les araignées tout ça
puis on découvre de nouvelles espèces
c'est très instructif parce qu'en fait
on côtoie un tas d'insectes qu'on ne
connaît pas pas surprenant mais très
très intéressant le site restera gratuit
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août à la
rentrée le tarif sera de 7 euros pour
les adultes et 4 euros pour les enfants